Rất chứa từng trải nghiệm của cái cú rơ kinh điện này
Chứ nên họ vẫn còn hơi khi vọng về cái su lực tăng của chịu truyền
Chứ rồi, lâu thứ vào bán
Chúng rồi, ý thông, lâu thứ vào bán
Mới mẹ có người nãy nhé cũng mừng là bà của chịu đầu cơ
Là lâu thứ bà thì tui sui là
Môi đẹp ấy, môi đẹp ấy, tây con phạm của quên đi
Nhi nghĩa người lâu thứ bà
Chứ rồi ra khảm đơi bởi vì chá nó tập nông qua
Chứ rồi, lâu thứ tích cái tâm biến mong hút
Thích cái vọng bọng bọng họng
Chứ rồi, lâu đầu tương về xa hạc
Lâu thứ bà có người nãy nhé
Môi có thể là chịu tập tiền biến với nhé
Là lâu thứ tâm biến không bị quá lực tình nếu
Lâu thứ có người nãy xả chịu
Môi đẹp xíc nơi, bán nhé và mỗi ngày mình sẽ bà gá
Để xe phạp đẹp xảm đình
Tham nhé, kì lắm sẽ có thể là cái đẹp xảm
Điều tên mẹn lựa trọng
Thích sự là vui bán hức người nông ở dưới tất cả trạng qua
Để vui lọng ý ra từ bốn chỉ trở lại thông môi mình
Về lúc bà sáng chở thì xa mốn nhanh sồ đông
Nhưng mà bà tìm ở đi lắm thì mới lên nhanh chứ được tương
Trên nãy để trở tình trả nghiệm
Cái dưới trạng ở dưới đi nhé
Thôi khỏi bởi vì con, thôi hi ghi vọng
Để gây xung lực tăng của cái chứa
Bà đi
Thái dành là cái vực giảng
Là bà mình phải chăm trị của ta là người nhé.
Rồi anh thì nha đột thức của ở siêu trình dưới nào,
họ bị tên ông sau và bị đi mùa ở cái bán.
Ở thịn là đột thức ở cái mùa bắt mùa,
phải cắt lộ.
Và cái thế thì nha đánh chăm chọt như thế già.
Ở bên nhà mình thì chung nó tương đối lên khách thì rồi.
Nó đá khó được chức của chấp,
là một cái mùa đi bán mùa,
nhưng mà chính như thế thì chung mùa đi bán mại để nha đột thức ở siêu trình dưới nào.
Để chung nó tương vạc, chung nó bán,
thì phạc bán rất là khách.
Tối mặt bán chế đồng tương vạc.
Và nhớ là hả phải,
đừng nhậu khi xong hơi lực đủ đôi.
Là tăng là phải đúng không?
Chắc mùa đi.
Phà mốt, lâu phía là đồng tương vạc,
thì nên nếu phà mùa có lạc,
bởi chân nhau bị bà chíu,
thì chương mùa phải tăng.
Cái trang niệm đánh mức nào thì bệnh mức nào thì bệnh mức nào thì bệnh có loại
Cái không có mơ người phía xương nào mà mở mở ra đánh thạch